[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نريد أن يختبر الضيوف
شيئًا لم يجربوه
في حياتهم اليومية العادية أو
لهذا الأمر في هذه المنطقة ، فإن أصحابها
أرادوا شيئًا فريدًا لمودم
شيء غير موجود في  ليس فقط
في دبي ولكن في المنطقة بأكملها ،
توصلوا إلى فكرة قاموا
بتعديلها وفقًا للمعايير
الثقافية للمنطقة
[الموسيقى]
كما ترون البيئة هنا
دون الصفر ، لذا فهي ليست مكانًا
يمكننا القيام بتجربة تناول الطعام بالخارج
وللأطفال لدينا عناصر
مثل الكعك وحاولنا إضافة
مفاهيم مماثلة مثل الآن حاولنا
إضافة فشار النيتروجين
[موسيقى]
لدينا فريق من كارفرز  الذين قدموا من
اليابان ، لذلك كانت الفكرة هذا العام هي
تأسيسها على الثقافة العربية للفريق العربي
، ولهذا السبب أعني أن
الصقور وهوليداي إن والجني قاما
بتغطية فنجان القهوة
[موسيقى]
أنت